[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paris schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen alles wichtige zum
letzten olympia tag und mehr vom sport
erfahren wir von norbert lehmann
werfen wir einen blick auf die großen
themen dieser sendung feuerkatastrophe
in griechenland die brände auf der insel
euböa sind weiter außer kontrolle
die wut auf die behörden nimmt zu
taliban auf dem vormarsch nach dem abzug
der internationalen truppen aus
afghanistan erobern die islamisten jetzt
auch kundus die olympischen spiele sind
zu ende japan verabschiedet sich von den
athletinnen und athleten wegen corona
wieder vor leeren rängen
seit die brände vor athen zumindest
einigermaßen unter kontrolle sind
konzentrieren sich die einsatzkräfte mit
ihren löschflugzeugen und der hilfe aus
dem ausland auf die anderen verheerenden
feuer in griechenland
dazu kommt auch noch die hitzewelle seit
wochen extrem hohe temperaturen
drei große feuer würden auf der
halbinsel peloponnes noch gefährlicher
ist es auf der insel nordöstlich von
athen
hier brennen riesige waldflächen volker
duschek über die schwierigen
löscharbeiten
wer auf euer feuer löschen will muss aus
der luft kommen zu wenig straßen in dem
ohnehin gebühr gegen und zerklüfteten
norden der insel
es brennt den sechsten tag in folge
35.000 hektar wald sind verschwunden und
es werden noch mehr werden
knapp 600 feuerwehrleute sind einfach zu
wenig um die flächenbrände in den griff
zu bekommen
wer kann flieht aufs festland 2000
menschen einheimische und urlauber haben
die insel schon verlassen
viele sind erzürnt sie glauben die
regierung in athen habe sie im stich
gelassen um erst die brände nahe der
hauptstadt zu löschen
schande über die die uns regieren und
über alle 300 parlamentsabgeordneten
wir haben unser wochenendhaus trüben es
ist heil geblieben aber drum herum ist
alles ausgebrannt
viele menschen dort haben von der harz
produktion in den pinienwäldern gelebt
für die ist alles vorbei
die können bestenfalls in 20 jahren
wieder etwas verkaufen allen helfern
macht die hitze zu schaffen 40 grad und
mehr feuerwehrleute behaupten dass ihr
wasser aus den löschflugzeugen schon
verdunste bevor es die flammen erreicht
die hilfswelle rollt an helfer aus dem
ausland sind unterwegs auch aus
deutschland
die schadensbilanz ist verheerend
innerhalb von zehn tagen sind in
griechenland 56.000 hektar land
verbrannt das ist mehr als 30 mal so
viel wie in den vergangenen jahren und
für uns vor ort ist dominik les meister
dominik sie waren eben an einer siedlung
die vom feuer bedroht ist was es
passiert ja wir müssen diese position
verlassen weil das feuer ist immer näher
gekommen
und wir sind jetzt hier am strand wir
haben uns zurückgezogen weil die brände
diese diesen ort auch bedrohungen und
wir sind hier mit vielen anderen
menschen am strand diese fähre hinter
mir wird uns auch notfalls überbringen
aufs festland aber wir selbst sind jetzt
auch eingeschlossen die straße auf der
wir hergekommen sind ist auch von den
feuern betroffen das zeigt wie
dramatisch die situation die aufhörst
wir haben das eben auch im beitrag
gesehen wie schwer es ist zu löschen
wie sind denn die feuer auf der insel
unter kontrolle kriegen also es fehlt
hier einfach ein feuerwehrleuten und man
hat das problem dass man ein großteil
der brände nur am boden in den griff
bekommen kann man hat zwar durch
flugzeuge eingesetzt aber das wird man
in der nacht jetzt nicht machen können
und auch man sieht es im hintergrund die
asche der rauch ist es ist recht extrem
hier
deswegen können auch ein teil dieser
flugzeuge gar nicht mehr fliegen und das
wird hier eine eine extreme nacht werden
auf dieser insel namen und es wird für
viele menschen werden wahrscheinlich
auch rüber müssen aufs festland mit
diesen fairen mit kriegsschiffen die
auch die griechische marine auf dem
mittelmeer hier positioniert in der igs
notfalls auch um einzugreifen und die
menschen rüberzubringen in vielen dank
für diese schilderung dominik
löschmeister kaum ist ein großteil der
internationalen truppen aus afghanistan
abgezogen schon nehmen die
islamistischen taliban ein gebiet nach
dem anderen ein
seit freitag haben sie mehrere
provinzhauptstädte überrannt am frühen
morgen eroberten sie offenbar auch
kundus in der nähe der strategisch
wichtigen stadt hatte die bundeswehr
lange ein großes feldlager bis zuletzt
wurden dort afghanische soldaten
ausgebildet thomas garcia berichtet
häuser brennen kundus unter beschuss
gefechte auf den straßen zivilisten
flüchten in panik milizen versuchen
verzweifelt ihre stadt zu verteidigen
doch es ist zu spät sie sind da tausende
taliban
sie kontrollieren die stadt und immer
mehr das land erst eroberten sie flächen
seit im mai internationale truppen
abgezogen und seit drei tagen fünf
provinzhauptstädte darunter heute auch
kundus davon war die bundeswehr mehr als
ein jahrzehnt sie bildete afghanistans
armee aus damit sie die taliban abwehrt
und sie half die bevölkerung zu bilden
schulen aufzubauen
schulen die die taliban zerstören auch
heute bücher in schutt und asche
sie sind geflohen in eine schule die
noch steht etliche familien einige von
hunderttausenden unsere kinder sind
krank sagt sie wir schlafen meist
draußen niemand hilft uns wer könnte
auch helfen in einem land mit wohl
düsteren zukunft mit mehr schrecken tag
um tag zurück nach deutschland zu den
grünen von deren anfänglicher wahlkampf
euro vori ist nicht mehr viel zu spüren
die aufreger um die grüne
kanzlerkandidatin berbalk haben auch in
den eigenen reihen spuren hinterlassen
ihr parteichef robert habeck hält für
die bundestagswahl trotzdem noch alles
für möglich heute ist er im
zdf-sommerinterview
patrizia wiedemeier berichtet es ist
sein wahlkreis hier in flensburg wird
der grüne parteivorsitzende fehlende
stimmen aus dem saarland wieder
gutmachen stimmen die verloren gehen da
wegen formaler fehler die landesliste
nicht für die bundestagswahl zugelassen
wurde eine doofe ärgerliche situation so
robert habeck hoffentlich nicht haben
wir es nicht geschafft und die
saarländer auch nicht wir hätten dann ja
vielleicht an einer stelle zu schützen
können das problem war vorher
frühzeitig zu lösen aber nochmal das ist
jetzt alles vergossene milch
jetzt muss man vorne geschaut werden es
ist ärgerlich genug also müssen wir
sehen dass wir an anderer stelle umso
besser sind querelen im saarland fehler
der kanzlerkandidatin werburg ein
holpriger wahlkampfstart ist sei
vertrauen verloren gegangen ja aber vor
allem beim thema klimaschutz hätten nur
die grünen die erforderlichen maßnahmen
parat
davon handelt der wahlkampf dass wir
deutlich machen dass man uns vertrauen
kann dass wir anders als mitbewerber
parteien wissen was die stunde
geschlagen hat wie dringlich die
situation ist und die maßnahmen dafür
auch bereit haben während alle anderen
sich libysche schlangen sollten die
grünen künftig mitregieren sollen corona
testen nicht kostenpflichtig werden und
es keine allgemeine impfpflicht geben
man hat das recht sich nicht impfen zu
lassen aber man hat nicht das recht dass
alle geimpften und der rest der
gesellschaft und die kinder dann
rücksicht darauf nehmen weil man sich
selbst entschieden hat sein eigenes
leben und die gesellschaft zugeführt
insgesamt gibt sich der grüne
spitzenkandidat optimistisch die union
habe eigene probleme alles ist möglich
spricht habig sich mut für die kommenden
sieben wochen bis zur bundestagswahl und
das gesamte zdf sommerinterview mit
grünen co-chef habeck können sie direkt
nach dieser heute sendung sehen
der schriftsteller und essayist
christoph ransmayr hat im schloss
bellevue den ludwig börne preis erhalten
die laudatio hielt bundespräsident
persönlich ransmayrs literarische
fantasie mühelos durch die zeiten so
frank walter steinmeier
große erfolge feierte der österreicher
mit romanen wie der fliegende berg & cox
oder der lauf der zeit
und jetzt kommen wir zum abschluss der
olympischen sommerspiele in tokio
arbeitet ja das waren wirklich besondere
spiele fast ohne publikum und unter
strengen chor ohne auflagen dennoch
liegt das größte sportereignis der welt
ziemlich reibungslos und begeisterte
sportler und milliarden tv zuschauer
ein gänsehautmoment die olympischen
ringe ins stadion projiziert noch einmal
präsentierten sich die teams dieser
spiele spiele bei denen vielen
japanerinnen und japaner nicht immer
nach party war dank gab es von ioc
präsident bach an japan an die
athletinnen und athleten in diesen
schwierigen zeiten gibt ihr der welt das
wertvollste geschenk hoffnung eine
botschaft an der jedoch ein preisschild
klebt mit umgerechnet rund 25 milliarden
euro werden es wohl die teuersten
spieler aller zeiten
die verschärften corona maßnahmen
fressen die ohnehin geringen einnahmen
möglicherweise auf es wäre eine teure
rechnung für die einheimischen das
olympische feuer ist aus 2024 soll es in
paris wieder brennen dann hoffentlich
wieder mit fans in den stadien
das deutsche olympiateam schnitt in
tokio mit der schlechtesten
medaillenbilanz bei sommerspielen seit
der wiedervereinigung ab und verpasste
am schluss der knapp eine medaille
bahnrad weltmeisterin emma hinzu wurde
im sprintrennen vierte sie hatte bereits
silber im team sprint gewonnen
abschiedstränen war die hundemesse der
sechsmalige weltfußballer verlässt
seinen herzensverein fc barcelona und
wechselt wahrscheinlich nach paris große
emotionen zum abschied einer
einzigartigen zweisamkeit lionel messi
wird nach 21 jahren den verein seines
herzens verlassen
als 13 jähriger war er aus argentinien
zum fc barcelona gekommen gewann mit dem
verein insgesamt 35 titel ein
fussballerisches lebenswerk der ich kann
versichern dass ich alles mir mögliche
getan habe um bei barca zu bleiben
doch der hoch verschuldete verein kann
messi nicht halten und muss ihn
wahrscheinlich zum pse nach paris ziehen
lassen
das wort danke schön und wir haben noch
die wetteraussichten für sie der tag
beginnt freundlich dann vor allem in der
nordwesthälfte und an den alpen schauer
und gewitter im nordwesten stark böiger
südwestwind 19 bis 25 grad
um 21.45 begrüßt sie in marietta slomka
beim heute journal
und jetzt geht sie erst mal direkt
weiter mit dem zdf sommerinterview
fragen von sharp hinterland banerjee an
grünen co chef robert habeck schön
sonntagabend noch